- All right, y'all.
Let's wrap up with something
fun I found on social media
perfect for this particular hour.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
So earlier today, we met
Lenny, the dancing doorman.
You saw those skills,
you were jealous, I know.
Well, just across the
pond in Dublin, Ireland
we discovered another
super talented gentleman,
Sean, the singing doorman.
He often greets shoppers at
a high-end department store
with a smile and tune.
And he's been known to get nearby crowds
in on the music as well.
We have Sean on the line right now.
What's up, Sean?
(audience cheering)
- Hi guys, how are you?
Hello from Dublin, Ireland.
How are you keepin'?
- Oh my gosh, I feel like
I'm on "The Voice" again
with Niall.
I love your accent.
So, Sean, you're a doorman and a singer.
Quite the talented man.
When did you start doing that?
Just start singing?
- Well, would you believe,
Kelly, I have three jobs.
I am a correctional officer.
Prison officer as we call them in Ireland.
I'm a singer in the evening.
I sing at weddings and kind
of corporate events and so on.
And then my third job, I'm
a doorman in a luxury store
called Brown Thomas in Dublin.
It's a bit like
Bloomingdale's in New York.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- If that makes sense.
- So, I'm like Superman, you know,
I have these different alter egos.
But instead of a cape, I
have a top hat and a suit,
and I transform into this
kind of singing doorman
to bring a bit of joy and
fun to the people of Dublin
and Ireland in general.
- I love that.
So, where does the singing come in?
Do you just, is it like a holiday thing
or do you do it all the time?
- Well, I've been working
with Brown Thomas,
which is the store, for many, many years
and it's kind of evolved over the years.
So, you kind of stand at the door,
you meet and greet the
customers as a doorman,
post for photos with tourists
and families and so on.
But the bonus is I have a front row seat
to the amazing musicians and singers
who are busking on Grafton Street.
And I sang with a guy
called Jacob Koopman.
Lovely, lovely guy.
He's one of the many very
talented buskers in Dublin.
And I took my hat off like
this and I sent it around
and collected money and I
kind of tapped the money
into his guitar case.
And I said, "Thanks very much,
folks, back to the door."
And it went viral.
It was the best fun,
you know, the best fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So here's the deal, okay?
If you come to Dublin,
look for the singing doorman,
and maybe you and I can,
we can do a song together.
How does that sound?
- Don't you threaten me
with a good time, sir.
(audience laughing)
Yes, I love Ireland.
I love Dublin.
And next time I'm there,
you better sing with me.
Mama's gonna show up.
Don't invite her.
(audience laughing)
Thank you so much, Sean.
I'm liking your post right now.
It's the first of the season,
and that's not all, my man.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of the Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate people
fearlessly embracing their loves
and passions and talents just like you.
So they're gonna give you $1,000
How's that sound?
- No.
(audience cheering)
Yeah!
- Oh my gosh, Sean, I love you.
I'll see you in Dublin, sir.
Thank you so much.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Seth Meyers, Hoda Kotb, Jenna Bush Hager,
Jane Krakowski, CJ, Noelle,
and everyone of you in the
audience working so hard
to spread happiness across this city.
We're excited to be in New York, y'all.
Thank y'all for having us.
We're excited to be back on the air
and sharing daily love with all of you.
Have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.
(audience cheering)